*Aacckkk*
That means hello
in garbage human language.
Hi guys. My name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know, your life is different now.
I'm in another hotel room.
I'm going voluntarily outdoors as means of a
small vacation type activity for the rest of the week.
I'm gonna try and post a video on Friday but I might not.
Doesn't mean I'm dead, it just means
I don't have cellphone reception
or wifi
and I'm doing it to myself voluntarily.
I just have this lingering, annoying thought that we're all going to die someday
maybe I should disconnect every now and then as a means to balance out my mental health.
I know, it's disgusting.
Don't have high hopes but we'll try.
But I thought, I've spent so much time in hotel rooms over the last few years
I have mentally developed a list of hotel hacks that might be helpful for you.
So here's a number that I will determine by the end of this video of hotel hacks
that might be useful for you the next time you're alone in a hotel room.
Take some bathroom towels or just use some of the extra pillows on the bed,
'cos they always put so goddamn many,
put them under your duvet cover so it feels like you're laying in bed with another person!
Best part is that person doesn't have a face.
So no one can prove if they're unattractive.
I like to make my room service ordering as efficient as possible.
Therefore I order myself numerous drinks
and then feel like I might be judged or shamed by the room service delivery person.
When my food or drink is getting delivered, I run the shower and close the bathroom door
so that the delivery person thinks that
these two double vodka redbulls are not just for me.
Pranked them so hard.
If you're feeling restless try using a suitcase stand to do some arm exercises.
Or leg exercises.
Or scare away any of the lingering murderer ghosts.
In a pinch, you could use the plastic bag that's normally meant to full up the ice bucket as a sock.
Or to smuggle back all the drugs you acquire on your trip.
You can just take the hairdryer.
You can use the ironing board as a TV tray
if you're that f*cking bougie.
You can use the telephone cord to help paint your toenails.
I know you're thinking that it's disgusting but you're also thinking that it's genius.
And you're torn.
I know.
You can take that informative hotel binder and remove all the informative hotel papers
and now you have a binder for back to school for free
-ish.
Use that HBO Game of Thrones promotional pamphlet as masturbation material.
It's free and you don't have to panic about clearing your web browser after you're done.
Well there you go guys, there was some of my hopefully helpful hotel hacks
for you and your future hotel endeavors.
Let me know which one was your favorite
and if any of you guys out there have any other hacks to add to the mix.
If you liked this video give it a thumbs up and don't forget to click subscribe.
Hit that notification bell too because I make videos Monday, Wednesday and Friday sometimes.
I don't know.
Ow